zwei jahre nach beginn der korona
pandemie kehrt ein land nach dem anderen
weltweit zurück zur normalität nur
deutschland gelingt das nicht nach dem
auslaufen der notlage werden nun hotspot
regeln konstruiert und maßnahmen
aufrecht zu erhalten ich bin der meinung
deutschland steckt fest in einem sumpf
aus angst und falsche interpretation
und es wäre zu sagen das ist begleitet
soziale dieser zentrum seit längerer
zeit was mit dem land los ist
meine erklärung ist dass das so eine
bloß keinen fehler machen politik ist
also keiner will am ende den
entscheidenden fehler gemacht haben
stehen da schaut schon ganz interessiert
wer einem dann sozusagen haften bleibt
und man ist dann derjenige der diese
kona krise und pandemie nicht nur nicht
als chance genutzt hat sondern geht als
derjenige aus ihrer vor der irgendwas
richtungsweisendes falsch entschieden
hat anders kann es nicht sein
oder oder
ich war der meinung ich glaube ich habe
so im november/dezember oder dezember
angefangen als ich gesehen habe micro
scheint deutlich milder zu sein war ich
mir eigentlich sicher da kommt was ins
rutschen man findet jetzt eigentlich
weltweit den weg wieder zurück zur
normalität mehr oder minder zum realität
normalität dann ist es aber halt
tatsächlich so gewesen dass deutschland
stück weil auf der strecke einfach
gebieten mit wenn man sich anschaut was
um uns herum passiert mit österreich
vielleicht als ausnahme sieht man ja
dass man da zu der vor pandemischen zeit
zurückkommen ist aufgrund der neuen
faktenlage durch omikron durch einen
fortschritt und so weiter und hier ist
man aber einfach auf dem auf dem fokus
auf die infektionszahlen hängengeblieben
und sagt deswegen brauchen wir weiter
harte maßnahmen brauchen sogar eine
nebenpflicht was auch immer da noch
alles kommen soll und das ist wirklich
für mich angesichts dessen was da
draußen in der welt passiert und einfach
rein beim blick auf die fakten sehr
schwer zu verstehen sie wählen ja die
die zahlen und das was mich stört in
diese debatte ist diese
eindimensionalität dass wir eigentlich
nur die zahlen anschauen panik
verbreiten die vollkasko gesellschaft
sozusagen für uns beanspruchen wollen
und nicht darüber nachdenken was die
maßnahmen und diese beiden jahren mit
kindern mit menschen gemacht hat auf
psychologischer ebene auf
wirtschaftlicher ebene und da ist der
fokus nicht dabei und das wird uns
natürlich auch in der zukunft massiv
beschäftigen und deshalb bitte
mehrdimensionale das ist schon ein thema
auf das darf man nicht vergessen das ist
jetzt nicht 100 jahre her sondern zwei
dass ganz viele menschen gestorben sind
ancona gab es noch keinen impfstoff
teilweise allein gestorben sind dürfte
nicht mal zur beerdigung hin familien
traumatisiert in den altenheimen
menschen ganz allein dem von
verzweiflung hin stöcken die wände
geklopft weil niemand gekommen ist wie
kann die politik das turnier haben wir
am anfang wusste man gar nicht was
passiert dann waren sie sich sicher mit
dass man impfstoffe kommt aber dass er
so früh kam war ein segen in deutschland
über entwickelt übrigens und deutschland
ist am ende natürlich doch besser durch
die krise kommen als andere länder wenn
die todeszahlen anderswo angucke horror
bilder aus new york oder bergamo die
hatten wir in der form nicht und ich
glaube die vorsichtigen man heute hat
auch was damit zu tun dass die menschen
sich noch voll von den kommunen
maßnahmen haben und nicht wollen dass
wir im herbst wieder eine situation
haben wir es zurück nach ein letztes
jahr schon mal so da dachten wir sind
jetzt durch im sommer kann das im herbst
wieder und dann geht es nun um die
freiheit von millionen von menschen und
dann sagt man da gut wenn die impfquote
bisschen höher wären sie ist hören
anderen ländern dann wären wir da ein
bisschen sicherer das ist glaube ich das
sage mir aber ich glaube aber ich glaube
man muss schon jetzt auch schauen in der
jetzigen situation müssen wir
rechtfertigen dass es grundrechts
einschränkungen geben und wir sind im
moment in einer situation wo co wird
dank der impfungen dank der milde
omikron eine sterblichkeit ungefähr von
der grippe hat also wir müssen doch
wirklich rechtfertigen können warum wir
dieses regime diese maßnahme regime
jetzt aufrecht erhalten das tun wir doch
nicht es macht doch keinen sinn mehr was
was diskutieren wir denn jetzt über den
herbst über den winter bei diesen
maßnahmen wir müssen doch jetzt mal gut
sein er nach dieser argumentation ist es
ja wir werden 10 jahre noch warten
müssen dass es irgendwie perfekt
aussieht das wird nicht aus wir müssen
mit diesem virus leben natürlich darf
man freiheiten die gehören dem staat
gehören den bürgern man muss das immer
begründen das würde ich auch sagen nur
sie haben natürlich auch heute immer
noch meldung am tag sterben zwischen 2
und 3 100 menschen kann man sagen
ankurbelt oder mit kugel aber es ist es
wäre aber gut zu wissen dass
interessiert habe eine riesige erst
einmal kaum noch jemand man hört die
zahlen achselzuckend die verwandten die
arbeitskollegen die nachbarn
interessiert dass sehr wohl und die sind
etwas mit den wissenschaftlichen sachen
ja nicht so sehr betroffen die gucken
sich einfach das ergebnis an und die
meisten wenn macht immer umfragen den
deutschen die meisten bürger würden
sagen naja der pixar tut mir nicht weh
warum wehren sich die leute dagegen ich
glaube mich bewegt was ich glaube dass
es nicht gelungen ist sozusagen eine art
ein szenario aufzuzeigen was ich damit
meine und ich mache zum beispiel und
beispiel müssen wir ja vergleiche hinken
immer ein bisschen als es mal hieß es
ist jetzt der krieg gegen den terror
habe ich mich gefragt man ist er denn zu
ende also da gibt es kein ende es ist
quasi in der formulierung schon drin
dass man kein ende hat und wenn man kein
ende definiert hat man immer auch die
legitimation grundrechte einzuschränken
und irgendwie erkenne ich in dieser
corona debatte so was ähnliches also es
ist das ende nicht verkündet wann ist es
denn um es ist mir um und sowie der
terror leider nie vorbei ist man den
also nie 100 prozentig gewinnen kann
kann man auch gegen diese krankheit
keine 100 prozentige sicherheit
erreichen und wir müssen uns glaube ich
mit mit dem lebens gewissheit anfreunden
dass ein bisschen risiko immer ist und
ich würde an einer stelle glaube ich
widersprechen sie haben die mehrheit der
leute der viele leute die auf diese
vorsicht wert legen zitiert ich glaube
dass viele leute auch sagen okay das
gehört jetzt zu den lebensrisiken dazu
ich habe jetzt zwei jahre lang alles
darüber gelernt was man lernen kann und
ich verhalte mich so oder eben nicht das
ist teil meiner freiheit und dann
erkrankte oder eben nicht und jetzt
ehrlich gesagt ist ja fast jeder
erkrankt wenn ich mich umschaue es sind
aber nur ich will nicht zynisch klingen
es gab andere zeiten mit 1000 toten am
tag jetzt obwohl die meisten leute
sozusagen sich mit dem virus infiziert
haben sind nur noch 200 toten da muss
man irgendwann doch mal sagen jetzt ist
schluss und jetzt es wieder feiert und
noch ein gedanke zu dem herbst mit dem
argument können sie natürlich immer
alles bremsen also ich war heute nicht
auto weil ich im herbst vielleicht
unfall haben ein aber das ist sozusagen
eine logik die uns aus dieser spirale
nicht aus ich versuche nur zu begründen
warum sie das feststellen dass 16
ministerpräsidenten sagen wir können es
nicht einfach alles aufheben eins ist
natürlich klar den preis dafür haben die
jungen menschen bezahlt ganz eindeutig
kinder die schlechter vor waren wir
haben sehr viel häusliche gewalt erlebt
haben gesehen bildungs nachteile gerade
bei denen die jetzt nicht so viel geld
haben es hat viele viele dinge auch
gekostet und das mit der versorgung
anderen seite ist natürlich so
deutschland ist viel besser durch die
krise kommen hier hatten an
kurzarbeitergeld gezahlt ist gibt es in
anderen ländern gar nicht wir haben viel
weniger wirtschaftskrise arbeitsplätze
erhalten geblieben das heißt die
menschen sind hier auch ein hohes maß an
sicherheit gewinnt hat auch die
härtesten maßnahmen von hohenheim ein
hohes maß an sicherheit gewinnt das ist
ein teil unserer mentalität wenn man
ehrlich ist aber unterscheidet uns auch
ein stück von anderen wissen sie
verstecken es wäre gut wenn es teil der
mentalität auch wäre vernünftig einen
vernünftigen datenbestand zwei jahre
nach der pandemie zensiere und wenn ich
höre dass sie sagen da sind menschen 300
250 350 im zusammenhang mit corona
gestorben da bin ich einfach der
auffassung der fordere ich eigentlich da
würde ich mir wünschen dass die politik
in der lage ist mit hilfe des lkw zu
sagen wer ist da wer stirbt er gerade an
corona wer ist da wegen corona im
krankenhaus wär's der mit corona im
krankenhaus und man sich nicht in diesem
ungefähren die ganze zeit bewegt weil so
haben wir immer die möglichkeit sie
vertreten diese meinung ich vertrete
diese meinung und wir bewegen uns die
ganze zeit im ungefähren und das finde
ich einfach einer industrienationen wie
deutschland nicht würdig das finde ich
nicht gut und so können sie immer weiter
die maßnahmen rechtfertigen okay aber
muss auch sagen manche haben sehr
geschäfte zum beispiel und den
intensivstationen damit sicher ich habe
selber fünf amateure zu lange und ich
hab dann aber da waren auch sehr
rutschig wo sie haben berühren dem
beispiel von menschlicher solidarität
und sie haben leute die sich bereichert
haben an schadhaften masken oder die
desinfektionsmittel auf
kinderkrebsstation geklaut haben und
also und zeugs haben wir gesehen weil
das hat doch nichts mit dem datensatz
ich will nur sagen bei den datensatz von
heroin blei daten ist immer für
wissenschaft gut politik an ich muss
auch wissenschaft hören aber kann nicht
nur wissenschaft betreiben und die
bürger sind fangen noch noch weniger
wissen schafft das ist ein unglück das
ist so muss man auch sehen die sind aber
viele bürger haben aufbegehrt und nach
den daten selbst gefragt also das ist
nicht so dass es kein interessiert wie
die also herr wollen wenn sie die
artikel veröffentlich interessiert das
niemanden wenn es neue daten gibt oder
na ja doch das
manche gesehen eine interessante ich
einen text nein natürlich interessiert
die leute doch glaube ist die aufgabe
von journalismus einfach die die
verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen dass das haben wir einfach
gemacht bei den zahlen der ungeimpften
geimpften ungeimpften instanzen den
bayern in hamburg und sachsen bekannt
gegeben wurden und dann hat eine relativ
einfache recherche oder einfache
recherchen ergeben das passt nun
wirklich vorne und hinten nicht und bis
heute konnten die konnten die erde die
die verantwortung politiker tschentscher
in hamburg würde in bayern auch nicht
erklären was sie da eigentlich gemacht
haben weil sich auch da alles am besten
im ungefähren abspielt und das ist eben
der punkt den der glaube ich viele
menschen da draußen auch aufregt und bei
dem die menschen sich da draußen
journalismus wünschen der einfach sagt
das sind die daten und das passt zu dem
was die politik sagt oder eben nicht und
ein beispiel noch von heute die
helios-kliniken ganz plötzlich geben
bekannt wie viele eigentlich mit und
wegen kur wird in den helios kliniken
sind und dann sich heute eine statistik
veröffentlicht aus der hervorgeht na ja
ungefähr zwei drittel sind nun mal gar
nicht wegen cupid als kurve 2 2 dritter
ich konnte es selber nicht glauben ein
nur da muss doch die politik darauf
reagieren da muss doch da müssen sie
doch sagen die krankheitslast ist gott
sei dank niedriger geworden oder gott
gott dank der impfung niedriger geworden
aber irgendeine reaktion muss es doch
geben kann doch nicht in diesem panik
modus ewig verbreitet entschuldigung nur
einsatz dazu ich habe das gefühl auch
wenn wir von wissenschaft treten dann
gibt es manche vor allem in der politik
die nur die daten oder die studien
zitieren die ihnen politisch passt und
andere nicht das ist bei longo wird
genauso mit oder an cholera gestorben
und das ist etwas was auch dazu beiträgt
dass menschen auch das vertrauen
verlieren die sie bei allem respekt auch
von journalistischen recherchen des groß
bei mir sie haben fünf wissenschaftler
und sechs verschiedene positionen so ist
es halt auch sie kriegen verschiedene
wissen die studie mit verschiedenen es
ist keineswegs so dass alle ihnen jetzt
recht genau so ist das
unglaublich viele wissenschaftliche
studien karl lauterbach liest in der
nacht drei da habe ich gelesen gehört
die zusammenarbeit nur die die in den
briefkasten
man mache sagen die wissenschaftler sind
eben nicht einer meinung dass man sagen
und politik muss sie beratenden
wissenschaft aber das ist ja richtig
diese sollten aber einfach stimmen ich
glaube da können wir uns doch einzahlen
sollten schon stimmen und ich glaube der
ruf nach den erhebungen und nach den
daten her rühren das ist in ordnung oder
einschränken da kommen wir alle zusammen
immer in der realität